Just received a call from my ecologist C.T.
for this afternoon confirms cancer is now in the liver.
You first recommended a needle biopsy, which I declined, I then said there are, he then
said there are blood tests to find, I guess, to further check invasive and no carcinoma type.
I would like to know, does Dr. Pettis change the right to further address the liver involvement?
Would there be any suggestions? So, I do want to address the first part here.
If there is thought that there's metastasis to another organ like the liver,
it's not uncommon that an oncologist is going to want to do a biopsy of that area just to
confirm that it's metastasis. But how would you know it's metastasis?
Because the biopsy would come back as the same type of cancer.
So, let's have colon cancer, but it testicizes to the liver.
It isn't liver cancer now, it's still colon cancer cells.
So, in that case, if it is metastasis, we don't change the right program because you're not
running liver cancer programs, you're still running colon cancer programs.
So, there isn't a need to change that.
So, should I do a biopsy?
Well, if there is not that the cancer is another part of the cancer,
we have multiple patients that have two different cancers at the same time.
But it's not common. Plus, you have to look at the initial type of cancer you have.
Does it come and leave a testicize to the liver?
Well, a lot of cancers metastasize to the liver that's a colon type for metastasis.
What's the chance of that being a separate cancer that needs a separate type of treatment?
Pretty slim. What's the chance of the biopsy causing more harm than good?
You could argue that that might be high.
So, it's nice that your oncologists will look at other ways to decide if it's the same
at no carcinoma type than to be able to do a biopsy and push you towards that pathway.
Most oncologists don't. They may strongly suggest it because it is the standards of care practice.
To do a biopsy, another site that might be seen on a CT scan or a PET scan.
But I think a lot oncologists simply said they wouldn't necessarily do that so they don't
typically push that harm. So, ended this question. Does Dr. Cutters change the right?
If it is a metastasis to the liver and metastasis to another organ, no, you don't change the right.
It's the same cells that are metastasis to the bone or the lung or the liver.
So, there's no need to change the right program. If it's a separate
standalone primary cancer, then yes, you need to run frequencies for that other cancer.
So, how would you know that? You only waited on this to the biopsy.
But you've got to kind of play the positive thing too.
So, the perfect example would be like, if I have colon cancer, then I have this pass on my thyroid.
This colon cancer, ever metastasis to the thyroid.
I don't think there's ever an any published data that the colon cancer would metastasize the thyroid.
99.999% chance. If it is cancer, the thyroid that it is a completely different thyroid cancer
instead of colon cancer. So, yes, then you would change the right programing to include
appropriate frequencies for that other primary cancer.